today the young people have their
futuristic things but I'm still about
not the past a quality craftsmanship
that's antiques
offers things for your home the chill
character keeping your wrist
check out the spoon young fella this is
handmade 1658 London England no way does
it still work
oh yeah come down see for yourself
that's it yeah I know it's not a lot but
okay listen I get you're new to
Hollywood right but your resume consists
of Community College theater and one
line in a local spot and your co-star is
a spoon right it is very hard to take on
a new client
although I do I do trust my sister's
instincts she says I was good right she
did yeah she said you were one of her
brightest and that was those 13 years
ago
so you've been in Iowa the whole time or
I ran into your sister Louise and she
was like oh my god Gary uh you know you
were so good you didn't move you didn't
go he didn't go to Hollywood and I was
like no and she's like ah you were so
you should have and I was like I know
I up
but I didn't I stayed there and I
should have come but now I'm here I
saved up all my money and I'm ready I'm
ready to act let me see your headshot
yeah check it out that's not a
professional headshot no but these are
shots of my head Gary right lights
thought you said it was a headshot yeah
just a picture of your head I mean
that's just what it's called but they do
full-body the new half way stop I mean
they do all of it
Wow you went full LA on me only took
three months well Rick if by full LA you
mean I have a manager now that's in
charge of my career then yes I know we
can't all just eat your ear all day like
a child or drug addict okay I gotta
focus on the shoot right now dude
turtleneck it's universal yeah well
makes your head look like it's
out a frosting turd whoa whoa this is
huge is palatial do this is so Hollywood
man so sick oh my god todd todd rare yes
thank you I love it finally my girl Amy
came through
you must be Gary hi I'm Todd Phillips
and welcome to my workspace I could
already tell that we're gonna have some
really nice images Gary
ready to book some jobs asshole
ah I'm Rick that's my buddy Gary he's
getting the shots I'm Gary ha ha ha hi
great right ok let's go out of Gary all
right you asshole did you bring
a change of wardrobe by any chance I
didn't because I felt the black
turtleneck was very universal and I saw
an old picture of Brando with it and he
looked very powerful and it was very
dramatic and that's kind of what I want
to exude through these photos yeah I bet
hey I'm on a tight schedule so we're
just gonna pop these bad boys out real
quick and then he could head down to the
waterfront right Rick yeah
right okay done
great job sexy good job oh wow that was
fast I wanted to do some other ones like
is my neck okay like how does it look I
don't thik and doughy babe I don't want
that hey idea why don't you jump in
we'll have a fun little quick photo
shoot Gary out Rick in I thought you're
on a time schedule I am we gotta keep
moving come on hustle hustle ah go yeah
well for Todd sure come on Rick yeah
Rick give it to me Rick
Doug face or no duck face mmm duck face
a turtleneck you look like you
have diarrhea it's Universal in what
universe we have to do resuit so how
does this work it's all right I can work
with this you can always play a serial
killer oh by the way who is Rick Rick
drove me to the shoot Todd did a couple
shots of them Wow
Rick's body turned his penis into a
mayonnaise volcano anyway
Todd's a bit crass Joe I'd really like
to see their shots uh okay
bye can you email me the photos of Todd
took Amy wants to see him for some
reason
yeah he sent me like 40 hmm check it out
that one's pretty cool why did you let
him do that hmm that guy just doesn't
stats up professional